[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor is everything with Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John talk about death
answer your questions bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and give you to be his advice
I did it a different order today John I
like how you're mixing it up and it's
very bold
it's refreshing it's innovative I love
it how are you doing I'm well I'm well
we're recording this podcast on a Monday
beautiful day here in Indianapolis
everything is going well how are you you
say you're well but you don't sound
quite like normal well I'm a little bit
tired okay
and I did go for a 5-mile run this
morning which is a little bit exhausting
but no on the whole and also I was in
New York this weekend which was also a
little bit exhausting very fun though my
longtime publicist and and your friend
as well Hank Elise got married oh yeah
so I was there to celebrate her wedding
which was lovely but I also am a little
bit tired and and what is new in your
life oh I don't know if anything at all
is new I had a baby shower this weekend
we received baby gifts it was lovely
people were very kind I believe we sent
some things to you as well I don't know
if you received them yet I did I sent
you a text message about how very very
nice it all was so well as you could
tell from the way it was wrapped up it
was mostly me who did the work well it
was very very sweet gesture not just the
stuff but also you there are lots of
nice little notes as well so we're
really looking forward to it yes the
thing that I'm most excited about is
that we got to pass down the little
dftba nerdfighteria onesie that someone
gave me back in like 2009 Sarah and I
even knew you're gonna have a kid hey
can I read you a short poem of
Correction for today yes you may yeah so
these days at least for a little while
we're doing short poems that also take
the form of corrections to things we got
wrong in previous podcasts today's short
poem of correction comes from listener
Andrew who writes there are no pokey
stops at high schools for legal reasons
trust me
I work at knee antic we
for the record since we're making
corrections is pronounced Niantic a
short poem of correction from listener
Andrew who is employed at Niantic or
possibly nee antic I still maintain that
nobody knows for sure how it's
pronounced
it's named after a ship that that fell
into the bottom of the ocean is it
really oh yeah I believe so I'm not
actually positive about that now great
I've already introduced an opportunity
for a new correction alyssa is it an
anagram of Titanic one of these days
we're gonna get everything right in this
podcast but not today it does look like
it's an anagram of Titanic except that
it doesn't have enough T's in it yeah I
also has too many ends there's a couple
things keeping it from being a proper
anagram of Titanic maybe we should move
on to some questions from our listeners
Hank as you know we got a we got to get
ourselves into the portion of the
podcast where it's okay to be wrong yes
right the dubious advice portion of the
podcast we're the only thing that we are
endangering is the lives of the people
who take us seriously
by the way do never never follow our
advice I hope that we've made that clear
over the years but there's just there is
no worse idea well John I can see in our
shared Google Doc that you're
highlighting all kinds of stuff so maybe
you know what you're doing no that's how
it's just how I read I highlight as I
read on the internet do you not do that
I do as well I try not to do it when we
are sharing a Google Doc though because
then it's it can be kind of confusing
okay yeah I see you doing it it's
actually super annoying when you do it
but when I do it it's very helpful okay
Hank our first question comes from Mimi
who writes Dear John and Hank where are
all the dead birds after 20 years on
this earth I've only just realized I
never see dead birds but I see live
birds everywhere where are the dead
birds any help would be appreciated
because their absence has become vaguely
panic-inducing to me Hank having I got a
say have you ever been to a grocery
store cuz they're full of dead birds
just so many minutes dead chickens but I
wanna like immediately restaurant the
Thanksgiving is centered around a dead
bird
we basically praise them like yeah
a whole restaurant just for dead birds I
don't think she's talking about dead
birds that you eat I think she's talking
about you know songbirds and blue herons
and most of all pigeons
well I yes so pigeons die in crevices
and so they are they they they they find
a little place to go die and I know this
because we have one of those places at
our old apartment where there would
always be a dead pigeon and we do like
take the dead pigeon out and then
there'd be another one it was like this
is just the place where pigeons go to
die is like a pigeon graveyard perfect
little spot they just loved to go die
there but in birds I think get eaten a
lot so small birds if there's cats
around they will get they will get you
know taken around hidden by the animals
who eat that skunks and raccoons also
will eat dead birds sure but also live
birds when if they are not feeling well
and are slower than normal so there are
lots of things that will eat them take
them away but also I think that a lot of
birds actually they go and die in and
they find kind of places to be alone to
die which is interesting though also if
you you know if if you are a person who
who looks to find dead birds there are
lots of places where you can go look
particularly buildings where they fly
into windows and will sometimes land on
ledges that are higher up than ground
level and they'll just be full of dead
birds if you want some yeah I mean I
actually happen to know where all of the
Pidge the dead pigeons are there there
may be some tiny subset of them that are
you know in a crevasse next to your old
apartment but almost all of the dead
pigeons are underneath the Western Brown
Line train stop in the city of Chicago
and I used to wonder like where all the
dead pigeons you know and then once I
moved to link the Lincoln Square
neighborhood in Chicago and started
walking under that train stop every day
I learned that all the dead pigeons
thousands of them are under that train
stop and I think you're right that
animals eat them that's the other thing
that happens to them but mostly my
belief
is that a lot of birds when they die
their bodies and their souls both
disappear from the earth at the same
time and are placed into an otherworldly
realm but I don't have I don't have good
data on that that's just that's just
kind of what I suspect but as far as the
dead pigeons go me me I don't know if
you live in or near Chicago but
regardless of where you live if you're
in the United States when a pigeon feels
that they are approaching death they
begin a great migration that ends
underneath the western train stop on the
brown line in Chicago so anywhere in the
United States the continental US that's
where all the dead pigeons go but as for
the other birds I believe that they that
their bodies and souls are taken to
another worldly realm Hank should we
move on to another question okay John
this one is from anonymous who asks dear
Hank and John as an American Muslim
high-school student I am often asked why
I don't celebrate Christmas as the
people telling me this believe it is no
longer a religious holiday I often like
to give funny and mischievous answers to
these questions however I cannot seem to
think of many for this particular
question can you help me out John can
you help this person out yeah I mean if
it's first off if it's not a religious
holiday how come there are so many
people telling me that it's a religious
holiday what okay so can we can we if
you're saying it's not a religious
holiday can we recognize the first
syllable of the word yeah I mean first
off right let's let's we need to find a
word for it other than Christmas if it's
not going to be a religious holiday
anymore secondly the answer I would
actually give to this question Hank is
that even if Christmas is not a
religious holiday it's a terrible
holiday because you know I have a
long-standing opposition to Christmas I
think it is a like a weird and totally
ineffective and inefficient mishmash of
different like mythologies that make no
sense when they collide together but the
biggest problem I have with Christmas is
that I have a serious problem with gifts
so what I would say Anonymous is I would
say like I don't love gift holidays
because
they are economically inefficient
because they result in me getting a lot
of things that I didn't want and giving
people a lot of things that they didn't
want and so what I do instead is not
celebrate this holiday regardless of
whether it is secular religious because
it is cray-cray I disagree with you on
some of the things that you have said I
think that gift-giving is and not an
economic activity it is a surrogate for
the showing of appreciation for other
humans and love and that's well then it
should be it should always involve gifts
that cost nothing or very little to make
that are like made by hand with the
sweat of your brow and with love rather
than like picked up at Target at
midnight on Christmas Eve
John this is America the the clearest
surrogate for value and appreciation
that we have is obviously the US dollar
well then we should only give dollars
for Christmas actually I wouldn't have a
problem with that Hank if we if you
either give a present that you worked
hard on that some kind of like craft or
handmade thing that it captures your
love for someone or you give them cold
hard cash I have no problem with
Christmas unfortunately what almost
always happens is that you pick up a
copy of Kinect for for somebody at
Target at midnight on Christmas Eve and
you're like remember how you like board
games that are really easy and then
they're like no I don't know I don't
remember that I wasn't me that wasn't me
oh man oh yeah I don't I don't feel like
I have a particularly good solution for
this somewhat complicated problem in in
fact Christmases it has there there are
a lot of ways in which Americans have
come to feel that Christmas is an
American holiday and not a religious one
and that is actually fairly separate
from the truth despite the fact that we
have a hard time actually recognizing
that yes I agree with you on that I
think it's really important to
understand that Christmas is not an
American holiday because Christianity is
not the American state religion
it never was this country wasn't set up
that way and it never should be I'm also
sure that in Anonymous's life this is
one of many examples in which they have
to grapple with a country that expects
you to be a certain kind of way to be
properly American which is of course
deeply offensive and wrong and again it
always has been like the United States
was never this this idea that the US was
was at one point like a quote-unquote
Christian nation is just ludicrous it's
just not true there was never that time
it harkens back to a past that doesn't
exist like so much radical regressive
ISM it harkens back to a past that
didn't exist so it is very frustrating
but if you're trying to deal with it in
a funny or mischievous way which I
applaud I would just say that I'm
opposed to gift-giving that should shut
down the conversation religiously I just
think it's an economically bad idea yeah
actually you know what Hank I want to
just I want to really quickly back up a
little bit and be serious here for a
second and say that I'm not always
opposed to gift-giving I'm just trying
to have fun on the podcast like for
instance I don't know if you know about
this thing but I recently received a
gift of 378 Snickers bars and it meant
the world to me so I do want to I do
want to just pause and say how grateful
I am to my friends at the Mars company
for the gift of those 378 Snickers bars
which truly is the gift that keeps on
giving because no matter how many I eat
a day there are still seemed to be a lot
I'm very sad for you when they finally
run out oh we got another question it's
from Dale who asks dear Hank and John
whenever I hang out with friends I act
in a certain way I crack jokes and I get
all hyper
but when I'm with a different group of
friends I kind of noticed that I act
very differently from how I am with my
other friends I'm more mild than wild
I'm worried that there will come a time
when all of us will hang out and I will
lose control over who I am and my
identity or they will think that I'm
fake because of this also I find myself
admiring people who act the same around
everybody their personalities never seem
to falter am I being fake how do I find
out who I am in depend
my friends or other people how does
anyone truly quote be themselves well at
the end there we got to a question that
is unanswerable but I will say that I'm
just like you I am totally a social
chameleon and when I'm with one group of
people I act the way that they do and I
feel like I just try and fulfill
people's expectations and I've I find
that to be fun and I find that to be
part of who I am that I act different
ways in different situations around
different people and I don't think that
that's a contradiction at all yeah I
don't know Hank if you listen to
invisibie lea but they had a great
podcast about personality and the way
that we think of personality as this
monolithic thing that doesn't change
that doesn't respond to circumstance
when of course that isn't the truth that
isn't the truth about people like we all
contain multitudes we're all shy in some
circumstances and not in others and and
you know angry in some circumstances and
not in others and that personality is
way less stable than we believed it to
be because the idea that it isn't stable
is kind of terrifying right yes yes and
Jo definitely feels that feeling and I
think that we are often told to you know
be ourselves and that can be very
difficult when we are trying to build
this conception of who we are and then
who we actually are defies that
expectation yeah how do you do how do
you deal with that Hank like how do you
make sense of like a self that feels
like it can't get pinned down that you
you can't really identify what makes you
you by the way I am asking this because
I'm writing about it and if you could
solve the problem for me that would be a
greatest I read a so it's probably the
the first like real novel I read I guess
I should say that Jurassic Park is a
real novel but the first the first
difficult novel I read was red Mars by
Kim Stanley Robinson and there are a
number of characters in there that are
this way
and that and that is in in a way that
was very appealing to me as a young
person and I think this is also true of
a lot of books that I like
that was that was praised as as a skill
that people were using to to their own
advantage and to the advantage of their
society and different characters some of
them were using it primarily to their
own advantage and some of them to the
advantage of society and and so that
made me feel really like kind of proud
of my ability to to change in different
situations there were definitely times
where I felt ashamed of it when friends
would be like why are you acting
different why are you not acting like
yourself mm-hmm
and and and realizing that yes because I
was in a different social situation I
was acting different than they were used
to and and so I certainly had have felt
shame about that and and that I you know
and like I'm faking to some extent but I
I think that it's that like the me Who I
am is a fun game to play and I can I
should and can I can and am able to I
should be able to and I am able to adopt
different different ways of being and
that's something that I can be proud of
not something that I should be afraid of
so what makes you you
is essentially nothing or is like or the
eunice of you is constructed partly by
you partly by forces outside of you and
that's just something that you're able
to accept well it's the thing that I
that I consider to be me to be to be a
big part of who I am now also I have
like there there are things that I don't
ever like that I that aren't personality
that I think define me more
significantly than my personality like
my values and hmm and like my like
philosophy of of how I should live and
how the world is and though and those
things when when they get called into
question are a lot more uncomfortable
for me okay that's that's actually very
helpful thank you let's move on to
another question that was totally
selfish series of questions but I
enjoyed listening to you talk about it
anyway this one comes from Peter who
writes Dear John and Hank have you
noticed that Hank and John would fit
pretty well in
place of the words Stacy's mom from the
song Stacy's mom loved Peter yep
it is your group but that sure is true I
can't help but notice that John and Hank
would also fit it just wouldn't rhyme
any no her
John and Hank it would be bad I don't
actually know the song I well you did a
good job
yeah if it were John and Hank it would
have to be John and Hank have got it
going Inc and that doesn't make any
sense
so it's pretty pretty much has to be
thanking John I've got it going on I
mean could he wouldn't it be John and
Hank have got a yellow tank John and
Hank have got a yellow tank yep yeah
that's pretty good I mean I've always
wanted I guess actually I'd prefer a
purple tank if I'm gonna have some kind
of pink I want a purple a big beautiful
purple tank all right well I am looking
to the floor to the fan art if I'm also
looking forward to the John and Hank
I've got a purple take t-shirt of the
dftba.com oh man I'm gonna just real
quick I'm gonna look up the lyrics to
Stacey's mom and I'm gonna let you know
oh my the the the video is predictably
here we go yeah I mean I have to say
this just reading the lyrics here on the
Google play music side okay I can't help
but feel that this isn't the most
sophisticated pop song ever written but
it would basically be Hank and John have
got it going on repeated four times and
then Hank can I come over after school
we can hang out by the pool did John get
back from his business trip is he there
or is he trying to give me the slip
oh my god it's like this was written by
an algorithm
Oh Fountains of Wayne I mean it's a
don't get me wrong it's a great song but
like so many pop songs it completely
falls apart when you try to read it as
poetry okay should move on because now
that I read the rest of the lyrics I
realized that I really don't want that
song to be about you and I at all I
think I think it would have to be fully
from the top down restructured for
hanging John yeah we'd have to we're
Dalit for sure so let's let's move on to
an another question from one of our
listeners all right this one's from Dana
who asks dear Hank and John I have a
slightly death related question for your
comedy podcast I feel like the phrase
live each day like it's your last has
been haunting me I keep hearing it in
media and conversations and it makes me
wonder how is that possible if I knew it
that today was gonna be my last day I
would want to spend the day having
awesome adventures and doing new things
with my family and friends I would not
want my last days to be spent like my
days currently are wake school study
sleep work repeat I'm not saying that I
don't enjoy life I just don't
necessarily enjoy it on a daily basis
how does one actually live each day like
it's their last is it possible why do
people say this yeah I mean there are
lots of cliches that I think contain
terrible advice but this might be the
worst one because of course if you are
actually living each day like it was
your last you wouldn't be having like a
bunch of awesome adventures you'd spend
most of the day weeping and desperately
trying to make sure that you say bye to
all of these people you loved and also
is my are my affairs in order is there
anything that I can do to make matters a
little bit better for the people I love
after I'm gone I just think it's the
stupidest idea like if you live each day
like it's your last for one thing you're
gonna be really sad most days but for
another thing you're also going to be
like I have the same problem with carpe
diem Hank because if all you do is seize
the day this day is the only day all I
have is the present then you're never
planning for the future which is a big
problem because there is almost always a
future like it almost never is your last
day so like you wake up the next day and
you're like boy I really probably could
have prepared slightly better for today
I well first I think that you are
correct if you live you stay like as if
you are going to die tomorrow and you
know this fact then you're going to
spend every day calling your family and
they're gonna be like oh my god no
you're not dying secondly though I think
that that that yes the seize the day is
more the expression that is trying to be
gotten across not that it is your last
but that it may as well be and and you
are right that only one out of like
thirty thousand days will be your last
day and that's pretty good
oh no more than that more than that yeah
and I think you should celebrate this
fact I think that like if you if you in
all likelihood have a future to plan for
at least part of your day should be
spent preparing for that future like
school is a good example of this like I
found college to be pretty fun but I was
also conscious of the fact that I was in
college partly so that I could you know
enjoy adulthood more and I don't regret
that investment of time at all
no I and I like to live each day as if I
will live a long long time and I just I
looked it up cuz my rough math I was I
was not sure of and it turns out that
John is it's the less than less than one
in every 30,000 days and on average one
in every twenty seven thousand three
hundred and seventy-five days will be
your last if you live in the u.s. so but
you you could you could get thirty
thousand days it's not like a completely
unrealistic oh sure sure yes yes it's
often often yes I'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed for 30 grand
that would be that would seem like
victory to me but yeah I don't think
that you should live every day like it's
your last I think you should live every
day as if you were going to have a long
and productive life the other thing is
that if you live every day like it's
your last you never save anything like
not just not just money but you don't
save anything because like yeah it's all
going away I just I don't have that free
spiritedness inside of me Hank I am the
least free spirit I have ever met you
are pretty you are pretty confined
spirit John ah but I also like I want to
say that I spend like a huge amount of
my days investing in the future like for
example this podcast isn't kind of go up
until next week and so if I was
my everyday like it was my last I would
not be recording this podcast so I'm
playing over respectfully I know I
wouldn't either I enjoy it but I don't
enjoy it nearly that much oh yeah it
would be really good as be like a so
John just found out he's gonna die
tomorrow so we decided to record a
podcast for you this is it's gonna be a
little bit of a of a more McCobb dear
Hank and John than usual which is saying
something
alright let's move on to another
question from our listeners this one by
the way you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com we always forget to
say that Hank and yet somehow people
find a way which I appreciate but it's
Hank and John at gmail.com is our email
address okay Hank this question comes
from Sidney who writes dear John and
Hank I need some dubious advice on a
very important grammatical issue it's
how to shorten the term as per usual
people usually say usual out loud as
huge like as per huge by the way when
Sidney says people I think Sidney is
referring her peers who are I'm guessing
24 years younger than I am anyway how do
you spell the huge in as per huge does
this make any sense I just want to be
able to write as per you jiaying in
parentheses I shortened that from usual
I mean Sidney you are my hero
on every level I love every part of this
question I I think it's pretty clear I
think it's why ooj it's not why ooj if
you write as ever why ooj people will
actually pronounce they'll have to like
pause and they'll be like as per you
Jasper you is that Donald Trump saying
huge what is happening with as per you
know you got to get to Shh in there so
I'm gonna go why oh oh Sh as per you sh
nope that doesn't work either no
definitely not definitely not it's huge
its depth Y oo j wo gh as perugia
that's whoosh that's a that's an
existing word wo oh Sh we can't use an
existing
gah gah but anyway okay I'm gonna go
whoosh also works I'm gonna go with you
DG ii ii ii is silent
it could be pronounced uh de but i think
that it'll get across huge this is an
incredibly difficult question hank this
might be the hardest question we've ever
been asked to answer on dear Hank and
John uh Y oh you Sh as for you nope nope
as per you Sh as per yuge
you should with a Jag you got to get the
y OU u z SH use y OU use e SH I mean
that that is definitely wrong I'm
looking at it I just typed it out it's
your clothes though I think it's also
more letters than usual just to be clear
well ya know there's definitely no way
to spell it with fewer letters better in
usual no why oh I J y oj what huge but
doesn't that doesn't huge sound like
Donald Trump saying huge it does it does
yes you've got to get the shoe and use
is it y ou oh Sh that's you sh dang it
ask free i y oo j sh as for you sh y IJ
h i don't dislike e yl o j sh although
it looks very weird
if I agree it looks very weird I mean I
don't think that I don't know if this is
gonna be entertaining to our podcast
listeners but you should really see Mike
and I shared Google Doc right now it's
hilarious it's just Hank and I
desperately typing out things that sound
vaguely like as for huge so somewhat on
this topic Hank when my books are
published in languages with other
alphabets especially in like Russian or
countries where there is no je sound
they use a mix of the like D and X sound
to make the je of like John basically
it's like Dijon and the sort of like
there's like sure sound of the X like
letter and the does sound of D and so
they usually translate my name in such a
way that I can sort of read the Cyrillic
alphabet but I always read it as like
this book was by D John Green and I
think we're running up against a similar
problem which is that the Latin alphabet
has no way of saying as per huge which
I'm almost gonna suggest any that even
though it's gonna make you feel like an
old fuddy-duddy you just spell out usual
because I don't think there's any way
that we can get to use with our alpha
what Jim what about what about the Oh
with the unlock Oh like y una loud at Oh
je oh that's brilliant
it's brilliant wait what do you what how
are you spelling it y ou loaded u je je
e with an umlaut as per yuge
no that's still jus at but maybe a tell
you I use a some what I'm hearing is use
e I can't type and added you apparently
I don't know how you're gonna act for
Sydney we figured it out but it does
involve an umlaut and i don't know if
that's on your iPhone keyboard but I
would go with as per usual I assume by
the way that Sydney has an iPhone and
text an iPhone it's like I feel like I
know her although I don't but as per
usual
lot is the way that's the way out maybe
just owed Lao did you je oh that's good
boom loud at you je that's simple it's
fewer letters than usual it also it's as
per yuge nope I don't like the je I'm
gonna stick with with Y allow did you Sh
maybe sh e wow it's possible that we
spent enough time talking well I almost
feel like we should start a spin-off
podcast okay where we just decide upon
new spellings for
abbreviations I'm into it or how to
pronounce things like Hank do you ever
wonder how to like remember back in the
day when instead of saying BRB if
someone was gonna be gone for a while
from the internet they would write afk
away from keyboard yeah I always used to
pronounce that in my head as f sure but
I've never known how to pronounce BRB
you know is it burb sure is it brub burb
burb that's that makes sense it's
interesting when we look at words that
don't have vowels the noise that we put
in I talked to a linguist about this one
time is this sort of like what we call a
like a neutral vowel sound I don't know
if we call them that but in English it's
a it's sort of a you sound like ah and
like burb buh buh
and actually if you listen to English
very systematically though that's most
of the noises we make are these earth
noises and we don't even think about it
but like if I just said about it that's
an a but in fact I just said ah bad
right and it's so like it's more of a
you noise than a noise who knows why and
how wing linguists figure this stuff out
but I was fascinated to talk about it
and that it's a really great story I
told that was a really great story but
it wasn't as good as the 12 minutes that
we spent analyzing counter right as for
huge oh I feel like we're probably I
feel like we're at a low questions per
episode right now this has not been our
best word yeah
today's podcast is brought to you
our best work you didn't get it today
did a thot gas results brought to you by
Stacy's mom she has a a purple tank and
she also has it going on it's easy to
forget that Stacy's mom has it going on
because they only remind you about it 16
times over the course of the song well I
mean but what she does it's important to
tell you because you're so distracted by
her purple tank it's true I mean it's
weird because like why do you really
want to hang out with Stacy's mom is it
because you think that she's beautiful
or is it because you wish to acquire
this purple tank that she's driving
around who knows or maybe just spend a
little bit of time in it today's podcast
is also brought to you by the Western
brown line L stop in the city of Chicago
containing all of the world's dead
pigeons and finally today's podcast is
brought to you by the noise ah the noise
ah it sounds like a you noise but it's
really just everywhere and everything we
say all the time ah speaking of which
Hank can we go ahead and answer one more
question from our listeners oh sure
great this one comes from Rachel who
asks dear John and Hank are people who
have a large internet presence and/or
have lots of information about
themselves available on the Internet
bothered when fans ask them questions
that could have been found on their
Wikipedia page for example I was curious
about how Hank learned so much about
science but then I realized I could
google it instead of waiting to ask if
we ever met yeah I get that so much
people email me long emails that clearly
took a significant amount of time to
write to find out information that is
right there if you just type in just
this the three words that you were
looking for yeah but I think they ask
you precisely because they don't want to
get the information from these sources
they want to get the information from
you like I have a theory about this that
we really enjoy learning from people
much more than we enjoy learning from
machines like I like to get my news from
people I know that it's biased and I
know that it's you know not a
particularly efficient system it's not
the only news source I use but I
enjoy hearing people's take on the news
as they're telling me about it
and I think that's like a human thing we
want to interact with people much more
than we want to interact with Wikipedia
pages that said it does sometimes get a
little bit annoying but I also don't
feel like people should have a response
for like a school report that's one
thing but if I'm having an interaction
with someone I don't feel like they
should you know have a responsibility to
look me up on the internet before we
hang out that's weird I know I agree
with you but there are times like for
example when the dates for when VidCon
is are on the website VidCon dot-com and
people email me Oh give me what the
dates for VidCon are and and I'm like
yeah I just I don't know what to say
like this is not the efficient way to
get this information if if I email you
back it will take a very long time right
in comparison to the amount of time it
would have taken to go to VidCon calm
and and look at the dates that are on
them yeah no I agree with you about that
stuff but slightly off topic Hank why is
your Wikipedia page so much better than
my Wikipedia page like like what devil
did you make some you live in order to
get like one of the best biographical
Wikipedia pages on the whole freaking
Internet well my Wikipedia page with
with gratitude to everybody who has
contributed to it is it dumpster fire I
don't know uh what you're talking about
oh wow it is nice look at this chart I
know your Wikipedia page has a chart and
then they sort of like imported the
chart under my Wikipedia page but it
doesn't look nearly as good I don't know
no it doesn't yeah I know your Wikipedia
page is truly truly excellent and I am
profoundly I would be lying if I didn't
like say that I am profoundly jealous of
it because I am well I'll tell I'll tell
you John I haven't looked at Wikipedia
page in a long time though the last time
I did I did fix something I remember
being like that's not true that's that's
not true that's not a true thing I saw
my friend Matt Taylor pain you last
night and I went to his Wikipedia page
before I met up with him he's a great
author he won the new
Barry Ward this year for his brilliant
book last up on Market Street but I was
I was meeting up with Matt I just wanted
to remind myself whether his first book
had come out the same years mine because
I remembered that but I wasn't sure if I
was like misremembering and so I went to
his Wikipedia page and that led me to
another Wikipedia page about one of his
books where the first sentence was
something something something and the
book was also selected as a New York
Times Public Library book for the Deez
Nuts that was it somebody went to the
Wikipedia page just out of the word Deez
Nuts replace the word teenage and that
was it was it that was there that was
what they chose to do with their one
wild and precious life here is something
that looks like that looks like
Wikipedia vandalism but is not under the
Brotherhood 2.0 section of my Wikipedia
page it says that our videos feature
lots of different things and the final
thing in the list of things that those
videos featured was intercourse between
giraffes as the thumbnail for videos mmm
yeah that's not nothing I'm super proud
of but it is true they did decide to put
that right there at the last thing just
so you had really things in your mind
well so what can you do Hank life is
full of life is full of regrets and it's
hard to regret those videos because they
got like 40 million views I mean John I
gotta get money for Snickers somehow for
free it's true it's not like they grow
on trees or just arrive at your doorstep
at 378 at a time because you're not me
okay let's move on to the all-important
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon what is
the news from Mars this week NASA is
testing out its new Space Launch System
this is the the new gigantic rocket that
will carry astronauts to deep space in
the Orion capsule the Space Launch
System is going to be bigger than the
Saturn 5 rocket that took astronauts to
the moon and it has big giant engines
that are very similar in fact almost
exactly the same as the engines that
will
took the space shuttle up but there will
be more of them and they are running
them at a higher thrust amount using a
different controller brain thing to
figure out how exactly all of the fuel
goes into the thing and how they adjust
the amount of thrust that's being that's
being generated so they tested this
thing out it's amazing you can watch a
video of it it's just seven straight
minutes of this thing just blasting out
energy and it worked great they've got
it up to like I don't know what this
means but they got it up to a hundred
and eleven percent thrust so that seems
impossible but they ran them for the
Space Shuttle at a hundred and four
hundred and six percent thrust so I
guess that that's the thing that you can
do and and it it operated well it seems
it didn't damage itself at all and it's
a step toward our future as a deep-space
society getting humans outside of
near-earth orbit and maybe to the moon
maybe to an asteroid maybe to Mars
alright well we will put try to put that
video up on the patreon page so that you
can enjoy it seven minutes of pure
energy being released out into the
atmosphere sounds like a fascinating
watch it's really loud yes I can imagine
in in AFC Wimbledon news Hank AFC
Wimbledon have acquired their first
point of the League One season
ah got a tie it was not a moment where
AFC Wimbledon bathed themselves in glory
Hank however they did draw nil-nil
against North Hampton away it's always
good to get in a waypoint that's a
pretty good result on the other hand
North Hampton is near the bottom of the
table AFC Wimbledon however Hank is now
off the bottom Sheffield United is in
last place with one point for the season
after four games played AFC Wimbledon
also has one point for the season after
four games played but has a slightly
better goal differential so we have
begun our inexorable
March from the basement to the top you
start at the top alphabetically
went all the way down to last and now
you're gonna claw your way all the way
back up well it's really important
actually to have had this bad run of
four games Hank so that at the end of
the season when they play drake started
from the bottom now we're here it will
be more a more powerful thing yeah so
I'm I I remain I was gonna say I remain
optimistic but that is that is far too
strong of an adjective I remain I remain
conscious of the fact that unlikely
things happen yes yeah how's that well
it's a thing that happens every day John
every time I'm driving my car and I look
in front of me at the car at the car in
front of me and and I look at its
license plate I think what are the odds
that those numbers would be on that car
right in front of me and there's nothing
special about those numbers but those
numbers in particular it's just very
very unlikely and it happens every day
the odds are phenomenally low and yet
the the unlikely it happens all the time
that's a big part of what makes human
life so beautiful and also a big part of
what makes human life so terrifying hey
what did we learn today goodness
gracious I don't know I I mean I'll tell
you I'll tell you the main thing we
learned we learned that it takes two
full-grown adults a solid twenty minutes
to spell the word huge I learned where
all the dead pigeons are there's like
six or seven of them at my apartment
building and thirty billion in Chicago
underneath the train station that's not
even an exaggeration there are actually
thirty billion of them we learned we
learned not to spend every day as if it
were your last yes yes hey we in the
course of today's podcast we learned
that John Green
spends every day as if he will have more
days no yeah definitely definitely
oh yeah definitely and finally of course
we learned that Stacy's mom has a really
nice purple tank cinnamon yeah it'd be
nice if we appreciated her for her
accomplishments rather than just you
know
her what she looks indeed it is not easy
in the United States even with our
relatively lacks gun laws to acquire a
weaponized vehicle and no matter what
the color no I mean in fact I wonder if
there is a purple tank on earth allow me
to google purple tank who can do it
purple tank-top no I don't want a purple
techno yeah it's almost exclusively
purple tank tops
but there is one purple tank I though
though two of the day pink for peace no
purple for peace please that's pretty
personal not seeing I'll tell you what
Hank I see a lot of purple tank tops
maybe yeah we've clearly there's just is
a very popular color for tank tops but
there is one purple-ish tank in in
slovenia i wish i could tell you the
city name but unfortunately those
letters do not go together in a way that
can be pronounced by human tongues not
does that yes i think that it's
pronounced yuge
I thought your abs gonna take a crack at
it but no no you went for the inside
joke thank you for listening to today's
podcast you can email us once again at
Hank and John at gmail.com if you want
to support this podcast we'd appreciate
it you can go to patreon.com/scishow
every month for our patreon subscribers
but you can also get lots of other cool
stuff patreon.com slash dear Hank and
John our podcast is edited by the great
Nicholas Jenkins our theme music is by
gunnarolla Hank I missed a few things
rosianna halse rojas helps us out with
questions our intern is Claudia Morales
you could email us and Hank and John at
gmail.com I just did I say an hour just
I definitely did you told us that one I
nailed I've said it like three times in
the podcast I've actually only said it
twice but now I have a strong brand
relationship with exaggerating so I
exaggerated because now that's my thing
well I was distracted while you were
talking read about this pink tank which
maybe we'll put on the patreon page as
well and yeah it's a beaut it's a beauty
as they say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]